all right guys bang-bang I've got a
special treat for you tonight in that we
have Preston who is uh calling in or
videoing in we're recording this
remotely so bear with us if there's any
audio issues once the quarantine season
is over we will get back to in-person
interviews but for now we'll stick with
the the remote ones so that we continue
our social distancing Preston thanks so
much for for jumping on and doing this
hey pop I'm a huge fan man I'm excited
to be here you you you have Litton
you've lit Twitter up with all sorts of
knowledge and I think people are excited
to hear from you
man I'm excited to be here I I'm just
somewhat flabbergasted that what we're
seeing right now I mean I kind of
expected it to get crazy but I wasn't
expecting it to get crazy in such a
short amount of time I thought it was
gonna be much more drawn out and just
this churn and it has just turned out to
be the exact opposite of that for sure
so before we get into kind of what's
happening right now let's talk just your
background and kind of share with us how
do we get from your early life to today
you know so when I went to college I
majored in aerospace engineering I came
from I went to a military academy I went
to West Point and it was very regimented
to say the least and that kind of shaped
my personality quite a bit just the way
I kind of deal with problems and the way
I think about things so that was that
had an impact that came with this
engineering problem solving kind of
mindset but I love numbers absolutely
love mathematics and so you know you go
into the army after you graduate and I I
went in and I started flying helicopters
I became an Apache pilot and but I
wasn't doing a lot of math it was you
know some of your flight planning I
guess there's some basic rhythmic
pick there but not really a lot of math
and so I just became kind of obsessed
with the markets because it was really
complex and I I can say that's probably
one of the things that really gets me
excited is when something's difficult to
understand and it's really complex I
just dive in I just really want to
understand how it works and so all this
time while I was in the army really the
kind of the fascination started when I
first assignment was in South Korea
after flight school
and you know just really started reading
as much as I could get my hands on in
the financial markets and one thing led
to another and it really kind of early
on I was like okay so who's the smartest
investor out there what books have they
read what did they think about and so it
led me to warren buffett I kind of
became obsessed with anything and
everything Warren Buffett related you
can probably see the security analysis
book that back there behind me I had the
whole thing tabbed out and highlighted
and just totally nerd it out on the
thing and you know 2008 hits and learned
real fast that there was a lot of parts
to the investing story that I still
didn't understand through that through
that event and just made me dig in even
more and so through the years I mean
I've been at it for probably two decades
nearly at this point just investing
personally and reading as much as I can
possibly get my hands on and then just
studying anybody who has made lots of
money in the market and just trying to
understand how their brain ticks and how
they've been able to pick it apart and
here we are
so yeah that's I'd say that's probably
the the Cliff Notes version for sure how
did you originally come across a Bitcoin
and kind of crypto as you're doing that
study you know I uh I was not a macro
person at all for the longest time and
believe it or not it's kind of funny
because I read Tony Robbins book oh god
I can't even remember the name of he's
done two of them the first one I think
it was just called money master the game
was the first one and in the book he
talks about Ray Dalio a lot
I'd really not studied raid al you
didn't know really anything about his
approach but Tony was just I mean
pumping him so hard in this book as if
he was the master of everything right
and Here I am as a Warren Buffett person
and just you know the the propaganda
from Buffett is that if it's macro
related you just ignore it and you just
look at the individual company and it's
kind of this ground-up analysis and
macro is too hard to understand so you
just ignore it and so Dalio I was just
kind of blown away how much Tony Robbins
was talking him up so I started reading
everything I could get my hands on on
Ray Dalio
like how does he have his opinion well
why is it structured this way why does
he have gold in his portfolio that's
nuts because any Warren Buffett person
will tell you Gold's worthless to like
all these ideas that were just they were
so counter to everything that I believed
up to that point and I loved it because
it was counter to what I thought and if
you study anybody who's made a lot of
money in the markets they they
absolutely love it when somebody has the
opposite opinion of them and they want
to understand all the reasons why so
that was me I was like okay I just tried
to read everything I can on Ray Dalio
next thing I know Ray had posted and
it's not available online anymore but
luckily I got the PDF and I printed this
thing before it was taken offline but I
mean his whole there's a really famous
video that Ray Dalio did it's called how
the economic machine works it's a thirty
minute video I would tell you that video
that thirty minute video is probably
more valuable than anything you'll
probably ever learn in a business school
economics class ever and I truly mean
that if you don't believe me pull up the
video watch it for yourself and I'm
pretty much sure that that's probably
the conclusion you'll draw at the end of
it well anyway
Ray had a I'd say it was a it's on the
Shelf back there to it probably 200 to
250 page manual that was the text behind
that video it went into a lot more
detail than that video
and I studied the living hell out of
this thing I mean just read it and read
it again and then started digging into
like all these ideas that Ray had and so
I would tell you that as I look at my
investing approach today I would tell
you it's probably 50% Dalio and 50%
Buffett as far as the fundamentals maybe
you know 10% you could shave off to some
other folks but in in general I'd say
it's a 50/50 split between those two
investors as to how I think about
markets and so that's how I started
getting invested where I started getting
interested in Bitcoin is because I'm
looking at all the things from the Dalio
approach and I'm saying this is this is
pretty darn scary now that I'm seeing
the world from a completely different
vantage point and all these macro
factors and you've got these 80 year
credit cycles which I was not even aware
of as a value investor with a Buffett
style approach but when you start
looking at those charts and you see the
ten-year Treasury that went up for 40
years and now it's gone down for 40
years and now it's at 0%
well what does that mean well we can get
into all the what all that means but as
a person who never looked at that I can
tell you it was pretty alarming for me
probably oh boy five years ago I'd say
is whenever I the light swells more than
that because I started getting into
Bitcoin it was probably 2014 when I
started reading all that and it quickly
led me to Bitcoin and I made my first
purchase at the start of the second
quarter in 2015 for Bitcoin got it and
so let's fast forward from that point to
today cuz I think a lot of people are
kind of you know holding on to their
seat saying what the hell is going on
right now and I think that it plays very
well into kind of the Bitcoin story but
what's your analysis I'm kind of the
liquidity crisis that we're seeing and
and the more macro factors at play right
now in this kind of financial market
uncertainty that we're seeing I think
the thing that a lot of people don't
realize is is they
I would think that a lot of people just
bias to whatever they understand
domestically and whatever country
they're at and they say oh I'm in the US
and the US markets are a disaster and
they you know this and that but what I
think a lot of people are missing is
it's not just the US this is a global
thing that everybody is in
simultaneously at the same time and I
personally believe and I've talked about
this on a couple other shows recently
that the reason you're seeing everything
so correlated from a macro standpoint
across all these various countries call
it the end call it the euro dollar I
mean pretty much any country you can you
can go to and they're all in the same
boat with zero percent interest rates in
real terms nominal terms you still got a
little bit left here in the US but not
much but the real rates here in the US
are negative across the entire duration
of the bond yield curve and what I would
tell you is that is no coincidence like
the the reason that this is happening
now is really because of Bretton Woods
and I know that that happened you know
1944 is when that happened and that was
a long time ago but when everything was
when the dollar was pegged to gold and
it was paid clear up to 71 and all the
other countries were pegged to the
dollar throughout that period of time
that's where you're getting the
correlation from as far as them all
moving together so when you come off of
that peg in 71 and interest rates are
sky high and they even went higher into
the early 80s because they were D pegged
and all that and they were still
printing and adjusting the money
multiplier and all that stuff but it got
to a point where Volcker Paul Volcker
who was the Fed Chairman and at the time
in 81 steps in and he says all right
we've got to do something about this and
he started bringing the interest rates
lower in inter of all of these dynamics
where we became a service based economy
here in the US the other countries that
were basically creating the situation
where they had to keep lowering those
interest rates where the then became the
manufacturers and the producers through
the next you know 40 years and 39 years
and that's where we're at today is they
kept driving those interest rates lower
and that there's your big credit cycle
the Dalio the
grabbed credit cycle that I was
referencing earlier that now your is
your percent and so now what does that
mean yeah and it feels like you know
there's a lot of people especially the
Bitcoin communities who've been yelling
and screaming about
hey if what happened already happens
bitcoins going to do very well and
there's a little bit of impatience I
think in the market really because the
lack of understanding around a little
quiddity Christ it's kind of this idea
that everyone's gonna saw every asset
they can to get dollars and that's where
you see the interest rates come down you
see the quantitative easing that was
announced etc maybe talk a little bit
about kind of how these credit cycles
right and kind of dahlias description
what happens at these transition periods
or inflection points or the equals a
paradigm shifts to some degree like how
does that play into where we are right
now so at the end which is where we're
at now because you've got interest rates
as your percent you've got to go back to
some type of sound money that's pretty
much the only way you can get by and
most of it revolves around the debt
markets because once you once you have
debt at 0% I mean think of your you got
to put yourself in the shoes of a 60
year old 70 year old person who can't
afford volatility in their portfolio
that has to have some type of yield but
they've completely banked on for decades
that they were gonna have that they were
gonna be able to capture five or ten
percent yields on interest rates right
so they're banking on that and now
they're there and now you're getting 0%
and in real terms you're getting
negative percent and that dog don't hunt
so you get in this situation where it's
it will not work for people where it
gets even more interesting is your
velocity of money when you look at that
metric over the last you know thirty
years that has just been continuing to
decline just like your interest rates
have and the reason that you're seeing
that is because the money's getting
polarized into the upper class of
society and guess what the upper class
only has so many yachts and only so many
mansions they go out and buy until their
kind of task saturated on their
pleasures and then the rest just goes
into more capital investments in the
stock market the bond market or whatever
and real estate or however they're
they're spending it but what's what that
does is that drives up the velocity of
money and then you don't see your your
bottom half it's not even a half your
your bottom ninety percent of of the
population that spend less and spend
less and then next year they even spend
less than that and so now they're at a
point where when interest rates get this
year a percent they've they've basically
bought back the bond market because it's
at 0% and that's what your quantitative
easing has done and now they've got to
start inserting cash into the general
population in order to create some type
of some type of spending right because
everyone if I don't say everyone but a
majority or people not just in the US
but globally or in this situation where
they've already spent it if they're on
credit cards now at this point and they
can't spend any more so now now you're
seeing ubi enter and I'll tell you a
year ago I don't remember which
interviews I said this but I said it to
people I said this is this is politics
agnostic this does not matter if you're
a Republican Democrat far-left far-right
or whatever ubi universal basic income
is gonna happen it's just a matter of
when it happens because you have to
stimulate the economy you have to keep
the spending going in order to keep this
fiat farce alive and so now you got the
coronavirus and I think a lot of people
are gonna falsely attribute ubi
to the coronavirus which is fine because
maybe it might help prevent a war
between nations but they're gonna
they're gonna tribute it to that but I
can tell you all the groundwork and all
the mathematics and all the lack of
velocity of money we're pointing in this
direction way before this coronavirus
ever came along yeah it feels like the
corona virus really is the accelerant
for
kind of a number of trends and kind of
forces that are all now coming to a head
and the coronavirus is in some weird way
a health crisis that's manifesting
itself as a financial crisis at the same
time and because you get these two
crises kind of overlaid on each other it
feels like you get monetary policy and
also kind of the government or a
regulator side all of a sudden they
realize we know we are used to dealing
with one crisis at a time when we have
to let's ratchet up our moves so it
almost is I said to somebody it's kind
of like they're used to playing chess
now they have to play one minute chess
and the second that they have to play
one minute chest that just means they
make their moves faster than they would
have wanted to do if if they didn't have
kind of a health and financial crisis at
the same time does that feel right to
you or do you look at it a different way
now I completely agree with what you're
saying you know if you did the math on
it and you were saying well this is a
one in eighty year event with the credit
cycle or one in a hundred year event and
you've got a pandemic that's a once in a
hundred year event you know one divided
by a hundred times one divided by a
hundred is a pretty small number and
that's what we're dealing with here as
far as how likely what we're seeing
today that's playing out I mean you
could you could make the argument that
we're seeing something that's a once in
five hundred year to a thousand year
kind of event slapped on top of each
other I don't think a lot of people are
gonna view it that way but that's
absolutely how I view it yeah I tend to
think you're more right than wrong in
that analysis so Bitcoin last week or
two weeks ago at this point had a
massive drawdown drew down fifty percent
it's down about 30 percent give or take
right now from from kind of pre the
coronavirus financial crunch if you are
the liquidity crisis a lot of people are
looking around the room and saying hey
is it over right and one of the metrics
or models that people use is the stock
to flow model to understand kind of
where bitcoin is and is it doing what
its
host to do we're staying on track I know
you've got a lot of thoughts about the
stock to full model and kind of how the
the recent price drop plays into that
maybe talk a little bit about how you
see those two events kind of overlapping
so I guess the numbers I always like to
look at is the start of the year so
although you're right from saying that
before the coronavirus kind of hit you
know I look I I personally was looking
at the current over iris back in January
and I was like this is going to be
really bad super bad because of the
videos and the numbers we were seeing
out of China but if we were just gonna
look at the numbers from the start of
the year because it just gives you a
little bit more context on performance
the start of the year gold is down 1.6%
Bitcoin from the start January 1st is
down 4.6 5% and the S&P 500 is down
negative 31% and people just gotta
understand these numbers you know that
it's just it's it's kind of crazy to me
how long people can keep their head in
the sand as to the performance of this
thing it's just somewhat mind-blowing to
me um so go into what you were saying
there about stock the flow so Plan B
comes out with this this article
brilliant article and he's comparing the
the stock the existing amount of
everything anyone who's listening to
this is the Bitcoin er obviously knows
what how this thing is measured
it's your stock the amount of bitcoins
that are currently on the market versus
the flow how many are being dropped at
whatever rate and when you're looking at
this thing and you're seeing how
accurate the r-squared value is on this
it's I've never seen anything like this
in trading the markets since I've been
doing it for two decades not anything
close to this and when people saw the
price and as we're approaching the next
four your having typically what you've
seen in the past is that the price
really starts to narrow its volatility
around that intrinsic value I call it an
intrinsic value or that stock the flow
as soon as the four-year cycle or I'm
sorry as soon as the four-year having
occurs you see that volatility separate
away from that intrinsic value or that
stock the flow value tremendously but as
it but as time marches on you see that
volatility kind of start coming in and
kind of become fixated into that real
tight price pattern and you're seeing
the same thing play out right now but I
think what surprised everybody with this
recent drop is is they were not
expecting this I was not expecting this
drop at all but I wasn't expecting the
supply and demand shock that we saw that
came out of the coronavirus at the level
that we saw it I was expecting us
applying to man Chuck but not anywhere
near I mean car sales down like 80
percent I mean these numbers are not
even fathomable for anybody that follows
financial markets like these numbers are
insane absolutely insane so what you got
to understand is the derivatives market
is just one giant I would call it half
casino and half risk mitigation I mean
by that is you have let's just say you
have an airline company like they're
trying to protect their risk in the oil
market right so they're there for the
right reasons to mitigate their risk
they just look at it as an insurance
cost but then the people on the other
side of that trade are pretty much high
stakes gamblers and people that are you
know speculators right and so when those
assumptions that are being made as to
what supply and demand is gonna look
like in the future drastically change
guess what you have massive impairment
on one of those two people's balance
sheets massive impairment and so how do
you how do you fix your impairment well
you got to go to Fiat you got a swap
straight into dollars into euros
whatever the denomination is for that
derivative you've got a swap into that
Fiat and I'm not talking about credit
I'm talking about monetary baseline
Fiat that you've got to swap into in
order to adjudicate that impairment on
those balance sheets and so think about
what we just saw we saw the biggest
supplying the man shock I think you
could you could argue the world has ever
seen right we just saw the biggest
supply demand shock which means you had
the biggest amount of impairment that
we've ever seen in the derivatives
market ever right and so if people don't
understand how big the derivatives
market is wrap your head around this
figure this the derivatives market when
you look at shadow derivatives you look
at reported derivatives then you look at
unfunded government liabilities all
inside of this derivative market you're
talking 1600 trillion right so that is
such a big number that people hear it
and they're just like all that yeah
that's a big number but to just kind of
wait to lay a little context to it right
let's just assume the gold markets 10
trillion just for easy math and that you
know you'll hear people say it's six or
seven or eight really no but let's just
make the number around here let's say
it's a ten trillion dollar market for
the entire global gold market okay this
is a hundred and sixty times bigger than
that that's how big this is capitalized
as far as the derivatives so when you're
talking about a 1600 trillion dollar
derivative market that has massive
impairment that everyone's got a swap
into fiat fixed monetary baseline fiat
in order to adjudicate all those
derivative positions
you better darn well believe everything
and I mean everything is gonna be sold
in order to come up with the dollars
that are inside of all that
capitalization to adjudicate this stuff
alright so just to say that Bitcoin went
down and has already had quite a decent
recovery I mean hold on let me look at
the flippin chart hold on let me do the
math real fast Bitcoin has already
recovered 50 percent
since the bottom of this derivative
event right and now it might not stay
there it might go back down that could
happen I know but the fact that it has
rebounded 50% off of that to me is
mind-numbing how resilient in
honeybadger like this flippin thing is
yeah it is absolutely incredible and I
said to somebody you've got to remember
that take equity markets for example
they've got the circuit breakers they've
got hours of operation they've got all
kinds of mechanisms in place to tamp
down volatility and do everything they
can to not have a free market because
frankly they're scared of what would
happen when you do have a truly free
market in times of panic uncertainty
fear etc bitcoin is a free market right
there's no circuit breakers there's no
hours of operations and so when you get
that moment where everyone is selling
everything the fact that it only drew
down 50% is wild and then if you look at
things like I think Nick Carter and the
folks at coin metrics did a study that
almost all of the Bitcoin that was sold
in that sell-off was Bitcoin that had
moved in the last six months or sooner
so it was no long term holders it was no
anybody with strong hands it was all the
traders the Wall Street firms the the
people who had just bought it and didn't
know what they were doing or kind of
knew into this and so I think it just
continues to prove out this thesis that
there's two types of people who hold
Bitcoin there's the financial
speculators and then there's the
long-term holders I don't think there's
a single thing that could happen to
shake the holders out of out of Bitcoin
obviously the financial speculators
something as simple as a liquidity
crisis you know they they couldn't get
out of it soon enough and you get a 50%
drop in a free market so I agree with
everything you just said and and if you
notice that was I had quite the smirk on
my face because the speculators that got
shook out of their positions and this
might be a really gross opinion for for
some people I don't know but for me when
this went down I was just I would
like this ain't nothing but a thing this
is just the derivatives market blowing
up and they have to sell their positions
these are all speculators they're the
people that I don't want to own this
stuff because they're the people that I
don't want to have influence in the
rebuilding of this after all this shakes
out so the fact that that that sell-off
pushed those coins into the hands of the
knowledgeable and the people that
actually understand and they've done all
the hard work to understand what in the
world's going on those are the people
that we want to influence and shape the
future let me tell you they are so I was
I just looked at it as a blessing oh
hell yeah this is great so obviously
there's all kinds of uncertainty going
on in the markets there's this huge
liquidity crisis we see the dollar
strengthening against other currencies
against all of these assets which kind
of leads to the asset price bleed etc
and then we got the feds response and if
we had talked a week in one day ago on
Sunday we would be talking about the 700
billion dollar quantitative easing and
the second emergency rate cut down to
zero interest rates on Monday of this
week we got the next surprise which was
infinite quantitative easing
so the 700 billion they announced a week
ago not good enough now literally using
the word infinite in or I believe
unlimited was another word that was used
to basically describe how much printing
they are willing to do in order to try
to get us out of this thing what's your
general reaction to all this you know
kind of like what I said at the start of
the show I think it was all expected I
just wasn't expecting it to unravel in a
week and a half that they would be
coming up with some of these obscene
numbers that they're that they're coming
up with I I was just not expecting it to
roll out it's such a gangbusters speed
you know they've got a real problem with
the dollar being so strong and it goes
back to a lot of this derivatives
conversation when you think about
when you think about everyone having to
settle these massive amounts of
derivatives by swapping in the Fiat I
don't know what the percentage is but I
would imagine the percentage of
derivatives that are denominated in
dollars is far beyond any other currency
by a landslide and so when you look at
the valuation of a fiat currency it's
all about its utility and how many
people need to swap into it at that
moment in order to make good on whatever
they're that they're trying to
adjudicate or buy or whatever and so
when I look at that and I say wow the
dollar is just taking off like a rocket
right now it's getting so strong and
then you think of all the implications
of that so all the goods inside of the
United States are now more expensive
whether they're they're actually a
product or there a service all that gets
more expensive which means all that work
is gonna be sent elsewhere in the world
and where I'm concerned is you're gonna
have another supply and demand shock on
the back end of this now I know the long
end of the of the derivatives curve is
already pricing when they kind of expect
that to happen but you got to realize I
don't think anyone has a good idea of
when that's actually going to happen and
so as as reality takes shape all those
derivatives are gonna continue to get
drastically repriced
as the call for people to go back to
work takes place or doesn't take place
regardless of where it's at if it
happens soon or if happens later all
those derivatives for that duration in
the curve are then gonna get re priced
then everyone's gonna run back to the
dollar in order to and I'm talking as a
percentage wise they're gonna run back
into the derivatives market to reap rice
all that and the dollar is gonna
continue to just go gangbusters so I
don't know how the US can possibly deal
with that other than just printing at
ridiculous levels to try to ease that is
people just don't understand how bad
that is for for GDP inside of the US
when you got the dollar just taken off
like that it's absolutely nuts
yeah it feels like there's a great
misunderstanding I feel like there's
been two economic lessons that people
have learned in the last couple of weeks
the first was what's a liquidity crisis
and how does that have an effect on all
these assets
I've probably answered that question a
hundred plus times on why are all the
asset prices going down and then once
people understand what quiddity crisis
is and how it works okay that makes
sense to me now the second thing that
we're seeing is I keep telling people
listen the dollar is strengthening at
some point they're going to have to
weaken it if they want to stabilize
markets and eventually drive the
recovery and all I keep hearing from
people is shorting the dollar would be
insane and you know all of these things
that are going on but I don't think
people realize kind of the systemic
mechanisms in place and the need for the
United States to step in and actually
weaken their own currency so that those
other assets are able to recover and the
only way to do that is to print a bunch
of money and flood the market with
dollars right they've pretty much exam
you know kind of expended everything
else so you bring up a great point and I
think it comes down to how people are
interpreting timelines and so you know
they they'll see a tweet where I say I
think that the that fiat currency is
doomed right and so the media conclusion
must be well press that thinks the
dollar is a bad place to be but they
don't understand it's it's really hard
to communicate everything in whatever
how many characters you have on a
Twitter feed but my opinion is in the
short term the dollar is a an amazing
place to be right now because relative
to everything else and you've seen this
play out the dollar has just crushed
anything and everything I mean it's even
out since the start of the year it's
outperformed Bitcoin by five percent the
dollar right now do I think that that's
going to continue to persist no but in
that short period of time as we're
talking about these derivatives blowing
up because of supply and demand the the
dollar in that very short window is
outperforming and I think as you see
these other if
if you have more derivative events like
this that blow it out that causes huge
surge for monetary baseline Fiat you're
gonna see the price of everything
probably to include Bitcoin get punished
through those events but then it's gonna
come back especially as they start doing
all these quantitative easing and ubi
and everything else that they've got to
do that time line as you look out
further the dollar is gonna get murdered
against gold and Bitcoin right it's
gonna get murdered against these things
and I think it's also gonna get murdered
against some type of commodities
especially things like oil in some
others but the timing on that is gonna
be dependent on when people start going
back to work and you start to see I
don't I want to say you're gonna see
normalcy again because I don't think
that will the economy we're gonna be
going back to is gonna be anything but
normal
like we're accustomed to but people
going back to work there's gonna be a
demand there you got ubi payments that
are gonna be going out that are gonna be
very hard to turn off and all of that's
gonna start plowing its way into what I
would describe is a fixed supply a fixed
flow of commodities that are gonna start
coming out and they're gonna they're
gonna somewhat perform like gold and
Bitcoin but not nearly at the at the
yield that you're gonna see on those two
in particular yeah the exam I keep using
with people is in 2008 kind of the
six-month middle part of sales
underneath when there was the liquidity
crisis gold went down 30% and then you
kind of elicit this massive or at least
at the time massive monetary stimulus
from the government you know kind of
hundreds of billions at the time was a
big deal and when they did that all of a
sudden investors realize hey my
currencies gonna be devalued there's you
know inflationary concerns etc they run
back into gold and all a sudden gold
ends up being up 3x over the lifecycle
of the 2008 - you know 2011 crisis and
it feels like same playbook just a
different day right where you're gonna
get that response from from governments
where they've got to bring the monetary
stimulus to weaken the dollar to
stabilize markets and drive a recovery
and over time you're gonna see people
realize today being in the dollar is a
great idea six months 12 months 18
months from now probably not the best
idea and then of course you layer in the
fact that what would have happened in
late 2009 and into 2010 if 50% of the
gold miners had just gone offline at the
moment everyone wanted gold right and I
think that's what we're gonna see with
Bitcoin in the Bitcoin having so it's
just kind of this story where I just
keep saying this is a script that even
Hollywood couldn't write to some degree
though they couldn't you're you are in
you know I I saw some people tweeting
that they're like hey how can we make
the simulation stop it's getting a
little weird for sure so what what's
your general thought process on the feds
response are they just doing what they
have to do like is this the right thing
for them to do given the set of cards
that they have or do you think that they
should be doing something else that
might put them in a better position well
they're in a unique situation because
they understand what's going on I I
don't think there's any shadow of a
doubt that the people inside of the Fed
obviously know there's something very
bad on the horizon I mean that's the
wall that's the reason they've been
doing all these repo operations that's
why they did QE for as long as they did
it they know that they're in a very
precarious situation the problem that
they have especially right now because
now you're in a crisis now you would not
only have to exercise monetary policy
you also have to exercise fiscal policy
in order to get enough money into the
economy so that you don't have things
start locking up and breaking and so
they're challenged that they have is
last time I checked when you implement
fiscal policy you got a lot of people
that got a vote on it and agree what
that looks like
whereas on the monetary policy side you
got basically a figurehead that says
this is what we're gonna do like you saw
today they're like hey let's just start
buying corporate debt through an ETF
like just nothing nowhere and I mean
people they're doing these things
because they literally have to and
they're doing these things and I don't
even know if if there's a legal
framework for them this
buying corporate debt like that I kind
of think that there isn't but I guess
we'll find out sooner or later but with
everyone on quarantine how are you even
gonna litigate something like like that
I mean they're just doing whatever they
can to keep the boat afloat because they
don't have to agree with you know 435
people as to what that looks like so I
think that's the challenge you have on
the fiscal side is because you got so
many voting members and you got so many
people who clearly do not understand
what in the world is happening they
there's no way that they could possibly
understand all the nuances of this from
all the other things that they handle
and what their specialties are and stuff
like that I don't expect them to
understand this but I I guess what I do
expect out of them is to not outspend
the tax receipts I think that would be
the the only thing we really need them
to do is not exceed the the spending of
what they raise in tax receipts we did
that we never had this problem but you
know they need to step in and they've
got to do the ubi thing I mean they've
got to get that approved they've got to
start getting money into the hands of
you know the working class person
because if they don't it's gonna they
could get into a real serious social
unrest situation and for people that
don't understand when I say the feds got
to do this the they've got to do ubi and
that stuff that's the reason why I'm
saying that is because if they don't
they're gonna get into a situation where
you have gross social unrest not just in
the US but globally and I think people
are already kind of seeing some of that
yeah it sounds like you're of the
opinion as am I that once they start
this there's no going back that they
won't be able to turn it off people will
get it just like the economy got
addicted to monetary stimulus you're
gonna get a population addicted to ubi
and and pretty much you know you ever go
to take it away from them you're gonna
have that same social unrest so you
might as well just buckle up and get
used to this as the new norm and you
know people you you've got to have a
transition into a sound money is what
what has to happen the speed at which
that happens is anybody's guess
I mean I I kind of you know you
obviously know my opinion I think it's
going to be Bitcoin and
think that I think the coming two years
are going to be beyond exciting for the
price movement in Bitcoin and I think
that this for your having that's coming
up in May is gonna really Drive that
realization for a lot of people
especially as all these ubi checks go
out and you got so many Millennials that
are just gonna plow it straight into
this and these Millennials have been a
condition to to find 30% moves up or
down to be somewhat normal you know it's
like oh well I don't have anything to
lose so if it went down 30% no big deal
and they're just I mean they're like the
pristine hot allure that you need them
to be that you know you get some of the
older generation I mean something moves
30% and they're literally cleaning their
pants so they say that again pomp I
didn't hear you I said they just saw
equities fall 30% and they're all ready
to like jump off a cliff exactly yeah
and I mean in in the Bitcoin space that
ain't nothing but a thing yeah let's
talk about the ubi it recently came out
I think it's Pelosi and some of you know
kind of her peers but doesn't really
matter who it is is now proposing the
idea of folks getting a digital wallet
and receiving these ubi payments
potentially through a digital dollar
what do you kind of take from from this
whole idea of everyone hates Libre and
Bitcoin you know twelve months ago to
now we're talking about potentially
paying ubi via a digital dollar into a
digital wallet to me it sounds like
they're speeding up the adoption of
Bitcoin I mean think about it you're
gonna have immediate clearance of
transactions in the Bitcoin so before if
they were doing ubi check step two there
Bank of America account and then they
had to clear it in whatever I mean it's
just I think it's going to be a faster
clearance of transactions time into a
sound monetary baseline currency and
there's definitely no difference in it
being pegged which is the issue so
unless and even if they did say it was
pegged I don't think anyone would
believe it so I know I wouldn't I would
immediately swap it into Bitcoin if I
received it and I think anybody who
understands what's happening is gonna do
the exact same thing so if anything
they've just accelerated the speed at
which Bitcoin adoptions gonna happen by
doing it so sure have at it
yeah then one of the reasons why last
year on television I started talking
more and more about the digital doll or
was I thought that there was kind of a
win-win situation which was the u.s. if
other countries were to digitize their
currency in the u.s. did not we didn't
have a digital dollar there is a big
risk to the dollar becoming less
accessible to people around the world
right if I can all of a sudden with an
internet connection log in and I can buy
the digital wan or digital ruble or
something like that but I can't get a
digital dollar there's an accessibility
challenge and therefore I'm going to
store my wealth in another currency if
for some reason I don't do it in Bitcoin
but then the second piece is well if
they're gonna digitize the dollar then
they're gonna have to get everyone
digital wallets and just like you said I
think that once you start handing people
digital wallets humans aren't stupid
right and they're gonna realize very
quickly wait a second there's one that's
a deflationary type currency that has
the ability to be provably scarce versus
I've got this inflationary thing which
if you look at the Fed's balance sheet
from last week literally it looks like
it went parabolic right and that they
added three hundred fifty six billion
dollars which is the highest increase in
a week ever right and so I think just
when you start thinking about where does
an entire generation of people put their
kind of wealth and where do they trust
well they trust the thing that they can
prove and so if you're gonna hand people
digital wallets you know what you said I
think you're just accelerating bitcoins
kind of rise in popularity I mean if
you've got a billion dollars and you've
got to send it to into another currency
and it takes hours or a day to get a
clearance of transaction on that
um you've got to take out some type of I
would think a smart person would look at
that and say all right what's my what's
my volatility risk for this specific
currency into the other one and they got
to take out a derivatives contract in
order to protect that with with digital
tokens you get your clearance at
transactions near immediate right so
you're you're you're taking that
frictional cost of protecting that
volatility risk through the time that it
takes to clear completely out of the
equation so you know the countries that
are going to be the last movers on that
I don't know that I would step out and
say that it's gonna be the demise of
that currency by any shape of the
imagination but it's definitely gonna
push people corporations and nations to
adopt a different form of of currency I
mean it's just it's just it's just silly
man when you look at when you look at
how obvious some of this is you just
gotta shake your head and just say my
god how are people not getting this yeah
mostly we haven't done the work yet you
mentioned kind of the demise of
currencies though and I know that you
probably more than most have and don't
want to work one studying and
understanding but also to kind of
articulating how currencies fail maybe
walk us through historically how that's
happened and and then we could talk
about how that may play out here you
know in our lifetimes yeah so I got kind
of a simple formula I'm there's probably
more nuances to it then than what I've
written down but I've just kind of
simplified it and so I say when you have
three things happen and they all got to
happen that's when you get into a
currency failure situation the first is
that it's not paid to anything so we're
seeing that we've seen that for I mean
since 1971 that condition has been met
the next one is that you have fiscal
spending that exceeds the tax receipts
and so we've had that for quite a while
as well you know you could have a you
could have a fiat currency and as long
as that country that that is hosting
that currency does not out spend their
tax receipts you're fine you you don't
necessarily have to have a
but you know human nature you can read a
book on human nature any any type of
history book will show you what human
nature is and human nature leads you to
wanting more and greed kind of
overpowering the other courses that you
have to choose from that are much more
honorable and so that human nature eats
eats away at that and eventually you get
in a position where elected officials
understand that they can vote themselves
money from the Treasury in order to get
reelected and when you don't have term
limits they'll do it and so you know I I
think one of the easiest ways to solve
that that particular issue as far as tax
receipts you know this the spending
exceeding tax receipts is you just got
to put term limits on people that's just
it's just too obvious but anyway another
conversation
the third condition that needs to be met
is the once you get the debt that's
that's issued in that currency on the
government I'm specifically talking
about the government debt once it starts
going down to zero percent and you start
getting real rates that are that are
negative and that's your third condition
all three have to be met then you're in
a position now where people are
literally gonna opt to take the fiat
have it printed they're gonna stick it
in a safety deposit box because they're
gonna get a better return than owning a
bond that's giving them a negative
return when you get in that situation
and those are contracts I look at those
bond contracts as guaranteed contracts
to lose money so if if you came up to me
and said pres then give me $100 I
guarantee you I'll give you back 95 next
year that in essence is your negative
yielding bond contract so when you have
all three of those met that's when a
currency starts to fail now if you look
at I hear people say well look at Japan
look what happened there they were at 0%
for years and all those conditions were
were met and you you also have to look
at where that money can flow globally
when those conditions are set and so you
had yield in all these other countries
up until recently and so now you're at
the position where all three of those
conditions are met on a global scale for
every major economy in the world and so
now the question is is well what how and
why would anybody want to buy a bond
today and for the people that you know
all the Wall Streeters will tell you oh
well I can buy it right now and then the
feds gonna push it more negative and
then I could sell it at a profit and you
couldn't get a more you know I I stole
this from Warren Buffett he would always
say picking up pennies in front of a
steamroller you couldn't get it more
picking up pennies in front of a
steamroller type strategy than that in
my humble opinion yeah it feels like
that's a very classically trained
financial engineer type answer right
which is how do I eat gap any little bit
of basis points of value versus why
don't I actually go find what the next
you know 10 20 30 50 years looks like
and actually bet on the thing that it's
not about single basis points it's still
it's about kind of paradigm shifts that
you will from from value so I have my
own business I know what it takes to
earn a dollar right anybody else who
owns their own small business or mid-cap
business that that's a founder or a very
high equity holder understands what it
takes to make a dollar people who
understand how to create a dollar of
value in society right they are not
putting those trades on because they
look at them as being absurdly
unintelligent the people you see putting
these trades on are taking other
people's money and they're the experts
that are investing it on their behalf as
their agent right every person putting
that trade on is not somebody who's
creating real value for society because
if they were they would never in a
million years sign up for a contract
that guarantees them to lose money you
don't mince words but you are definitely
not wrong at all right and I think
that's part of what we're seeing right
now is there was a lot of financial
engineering going on and when you look
out into the markets I mean how long
have people been saying hey we've got
over leveraged
companies in the public markets you've
got a pension crisis you kind of got all
these things going on and actually the
people who are calling it out and and
kind of most aware of it were the people
who aren't inside the system right
they're not in that legacy world that is
kind of blinded to all of this and so
you need those people to kind of check
on reality sometimes so pop I wanted to
talk about this going back to the stock
the flow if you don't mind I want to I
want to talk about an idea that I think
is really important I think when when we
look at a quote that Satoshi came up
with let me see if I can find it really
fast I apologize for the delay here is
I'm trying to find this on my phone but
you know early on Satoshi was talking
about ideas around how you would value
Bitcoin early on and he was talking
about a model that was very similar to
mining physical commodities and one of
the things that he talked about was this
exact model I'm trying to find the quote
here and I got this just for people to
know where I got this I got this quote
out of a book that's called the book of
Satoshi and it's a just a consolidated
list of all these direct quotes from
Satoshi I really like to study direct
quotes and not things that people are
you know well I think he said something
like this I want to read exactly the
verbage that that he came up with
whenever he said it I'm really
struggling to find the quote here hold
on one second my phone but let me let me
just paraphrase it and after I just said
that I like to have the exact quote let
me paraphrase it but if it's in - is is
he talks about how when you have
something that's really expensive it
incentivizes all those miners to go in
there and capture that price and then
whenever the price is getting punished
it they're they're not making money
because their cost is below that so they
start shutting down he's basically
describing the exact thing that we've
all seen play
out with the Bitcoin price through the
last ten years and so what I find
fascinating about all this is is he was
totally expecting the price of Bitcoin
to follow and track very closely to the
electrical cost but what I think a lot
of people don't realize is that as more
miners come online and this difficulty
adjustment keeps ratcheting up almost
like a noose throughout that four-year
period this this four-year period then
throws in this shock this with the four
year having it throws this shock into
that stock the flow ramps it up just
like the model is showing and then all
the people that can't can't produce at
that at that price right if I'm a miner
and in the stock the flow just increased
at an exponential level to what I was
just accustomed to I'm now out of the
market I can't compete with the lowest
cost producers that are maybe getting
their their energy for free because
they're harnessing a waterfall or
whatever the case might be
I drop out and so does everybody else
but then what happens is you get that
difficulty adjustment that automatically
allows this to become competitive in the
marketplace and then the price
stabilizes it as it goes up there and
tries to approach it what I don't think
people realize is that these early on
this price was heavily tied to the
electrical costs and as time marches on
and you get more of these four year
cycles I I believe that the price
continues to be bound by that electrical
price but as you get more market
participants and more and more people
that pile onto it the upside of that is
not nearly as bound and you can get in a
point a point where you it's almost like
an orbital with like a spacecraft going
around an orbit if it just gets pushed a
little bit outside that orbit it can
actually completely separate from the
orbit and it goes off and then it
becomes global money i I think that's
exactly what we're seeing playing out
and I kind of believe that this next
four you're having cycle combined with
all the things that we're seeing
globally with these debt markets just
getting totally the base
and totally manipulated might be that
final push that kind of kicks it out of
the orbit that it's going in and so as
we look at the may having that's coming
up and you're seeing the stock the flow
models showing that it should be around
a hundred thousand somewhere in that
ballpark right and it's not gonna it's
not gonna get there within the first
well it'll probably get up to that level
within a year this according to the
model and maybe even go higher but I
think as it pushes higher and you get
all this global adoption and then you
have market caps that are in excess of
trillions of dollars I think you're
gonna have traditional finance ears that
are looking at this and saying alright
clearly this is this is something that
is not going away this is this thing has
been pronounced dead 150 times at this
point and it's clearly not dead and I'm
seeing that the basement that's
happening and I think that as you as you
push this thing up and pass the trillion
and you start getting this buy and you
get all these various vehicles that are
allowing people to capture the
underlying price through financial
derivatives or whatever and I don't know
necessarily know if I would call that
what's a gbtc a financial derivative but
I would vehicles like that are gonna
enable this thing to kind of bump out of
that that stock to flow price that's
being held in there by this two-week
difficulty adjustment combined with the
four you're having when you when you put
those two together I'll use a military
reference so and and there's a great
movie scene that that exemplifies what
I'm talking about so if you ever watched
the start of gladiator and you have the
long bows right the the archers the long
bows they shoot their their their long
bows and then you have all the calvary
that's that's flanking going up the
flank around the backside they don't see
him because their heads are down and
they're trying the enemies they're
trying to protect themselves from those
longbow shots that are coming in so they
got their head down they're hunkered
down they're trying to protect
themselves and as they're doing that
that calvary of all the the horsemen
or going up around the side around the
flank where they can't see them and then
as soon as those longbow stop firing
they come in there on a fast attack fast
assault and they and they go to battle
and they catch them by surprise on their
side what I think you have there your
long bows and I'm using this military
reference people might hate it but I
love it they're using the long bows
that's your for your having cycle that's
the thing that comes at you when you
just think it's so far out there that
it's not correlated at all to a two-week
difficulty adjustment but then after
that longbow has been fired with that
four year having cycle the two-week
difficulty adjustment are your that's
your Calvary that's coming in and it's
just annihilating the living heck out of
the speculators and so those those
miners that are going in there and that
are mining this that are ratcheting up
that are trying to capture that price
premium that is that occurs immediately
after that for your having cycle all
those speculators come in they bid the
price astronomically highway above the
stock the flow and then the 2-week
difficulty adjustment just keeps
grinding it back down to where it needs
to be so why did why did Satoshi do all
why did he design it this way okay
because I'm describing something that's
that's saying that the price needs to be
fixed at that level for a four year
period before you go into another price
bump and then it needs to be fixed at
that intrinsic value for another four
year period why did he design it this
way my humble opinion of why he designed
it this way is because he needed
entrenchment he needed people to not he
needed this thing to not take off in
four years because he knows there would
be too much drama around it and that you
wouldn't have the entrenchment into the
existing financial rails in order to
stop it but if you can push this thing
out over a decade well then you can get
you can get tons of volatility people
are gonna write it off as being nothing
more than a speculators tool right
that's that's what the crazy people go
in and trade because the volatility is
over 60 percent annually so only only
idiots are doing that
and so you'd have governments you'd have
very wealthy individuals that would just
write it off as being nothing more than
a speculators game but yet the thing
keeps trucking along and it keeps
bumping its price up purely for the
reason to capture and in work its way in
as a Trojan horse into the existing
financial rails that's my theory what
would have to happen for you to think
either one the bitcoin thesis is no
longer valid or to something in your
theory is inaccurate so I've been asked
this before and I think that the the
concern that I have is that early on my
concern was that it could be banned and
that a government could step in and do
something to it they could stop it I
don't necessarily have that concern
anymore I think that what we've seen
globally there are countries like
Germany there's other countries that are
absolutely open arms wide open to this
thing in fact I would argue any country
that's dealt with dollar dominance over
that last 80 years which is every
country has felt the pain of what that's
like to not be a reserve currency and
they're looking at this as maybe being
something especially country and I think
this is why it's so popular in Germany
is because they remember it's in there
it's in the deep cultural roots the 1920
hyperinflation event with the with the
mark that they remember that culturally
they know how that played out and they
don't ever want to see it again so they
look at fiscal spending a lot different
than I think a lot of countries in the
world and so they're looking at this and
saying this makes a whole lot of sense
so as long as you have countries like
that it's never gonna get shut down and
that's what a shutdown needs is for
everybody to agree that it needs to be
banned and I don't see that happening so
that was my original concern I would say
now it could be you know the price could
go down you could see a lot of psych
psychology maybe push it lower if you
had miners that I think this would be a
concern if you had miners
that started really pulling their rigs
offline and they were not in the
business of swapping Fiat for payments
in BTC the stuff into their Treasury on
their balance sheet I think that would
be a concern and we have pretty much
seen the exact opposite of that and I
think you're always I guess my personal
opinion is you're always gonna see the
exact opposite opposite of that for one
reason and it's the difficulty
adjustment look at what we're going
through right now the price got hammered
right and there are many miners that
that became unprofitable because of this
derivative movement that we've just seen
but guess what the incoming two-week
difficulty adjustment that's due here in
a couple days it's dropping 15% to make
it more accommodative for them to come
back online and boost that price right
back up to the intrinsic value it's all
by design I mean this the game theory on
this thing is nuts and Here I am trying
to tell you how it could fail and I'm
still coming up with freaking reasons of
why I don't think it's gonna fail
because I've tried my darndest to come
up with all the reasons of why this
thing won't work and all I can arrive at
based on the game theory is that it is
gonna work yeah the only thing that you
didn't say that I answer the question
with is a self-induced bug so from a
developer standpoint there's something
that's introduced to the codebase that
could be like a self-inflicted wound
obviously given the development process
I think that's highly unlikely
but I'm with you in that there's just
not very much externally that I think is
a threat at this point and so when you
go to is kind of the self-inflicted
stuff well I love that point I think
that's a great risk to highlight you
know and when we look back at the summer
of 2017 with Jeff garsik right remember
Jeff did something really goofy there
right at the last minute that could have
really compromised a lot with just the
trust and confidence in the in the
protocol um
I think that could play out I
don't know if if that plays out that the
code can be adjusted people can go back
in there they can they can adjust the
code right the protocol and those
transactions or the the basically the
stoppage that you would see throughout
that period or they're going back to it
make that adjustment
I think you'd lose a lot of trust for
some people that are coin holders in the
protocol now would that trust go
somewhere else I don't necessarily know
that that it would long term it might
short term but I think is all systems
come back online I think that you would
have not everybody come back in but I
think you'd have a lot that would show
back up and they would they would
stabilize the market but I don't
necessarily know if it would cause this
this loss and trust spiral that would
take it down to zero I don't think
you're ever gonna get that because this
difficulty adjustment is in the four
year having cycle is going to ensure
that this eventually becomes global
money your there is that the trust your
concern there would be that the trust
would go into some other digital
currency that would be the concern but I
I can't name another digital currency
that's gonna give you the speed of
clearance like Bitcoin and Nick Carter
wrote just an incredible article I think
it's titled it's the clearance of paint
payments stupid or something like that
with maybe you can put a link to it in
the show notes I'm sure you know which
article I'm talking about but that's the
challenge for any competitor that in the
cryptocurrency space is that you have to
overcome that variable because at the
end of the day this is going to be money
that banks are using especially central
banks in order to settle payments that
are billion dollar transactions and if
you don't have a very thick layer that
this thing can go through as far as
transaction size in order to get quick
payment clearance statistical clearance
of payments it's it's never gonna win in
the long game in my opinion
yeah I want to finish up talking about a
volatility obviously volatility works in
both directions both up and down Bitcoin
as you mentioned has incredible annual
volatility but I think you and I both
believe that this is a feature not a bug
they may explain a little bit about what
that exactly means and why you
personally believe that so let's go to
the idea like let's say we were
designing Bitcoin from the beginning and
we had this idea of combining a four
year having cycle with a two week
difficulty adjustment in order to create
these intrinsic values these stock the
flow valuations and as we were doing it
we could do something that had this this
perfect linear intrinsic value growth
over time into the model and I think
that I think you could achieve that by
adjusting the for your having maybe make
it shorter I don't I don't necessarily
know what the optimal solution would be
but I know that if I move the four year
having cycle and the two week difficulty
adjustment into certain positions that I
could probably remove a lot of the
volatility around that intrinsic value
price and then I could have this nice
linear growth in the price so you have
to ask yourself why didn't you design it
that way or why didn't he or she or them
or whoever design it that way my opinion
is that it was designed to have
volatility on purpose in order to make
it look very speculative and make it
look like it was nothing other than what
crazy people do or maybe crazy people
trading and so when I say it's a feature
not a bug here's here's a here's an
interesting thing about game theory when
you're doing game design designers of
games and you can read about I mean
there's books out there on some of this
stuff but game designers use volatility
as a tool to bring professionals and
non-professionals together in a game so
let me give you an example so like if we
were playing the game of chess
highly-skilled game right very highly
skilled if I've been playing my whole
life and I've run those repetitions
through my neural net millions of times
if you step in and you've played ten
games I am gonna just annihilate you
because of all the conditioning that
I've done on my neural net so it is very
hard and not fun for a new participant
that's learning the game to play
somebody who's highly skilled that is
not fun it's terrible experience so if I
was going to design a game that would
make that more fun for you to play a
grandmaster at chess all I got to do is
is introduce volatility into the game so
now let's say that every time we we play
I do my move in the game of chess and
let's say that I'm the amateur and I'm
playing a grandmaster
every time the Grandmaster plays before
he plays his position he has to roll a
dice and the dice is you know six
numbers if he rolls an even number he
can he can play normally but he if he
rolls an odd number he has to skip his
turn and it becomes my turn again okay
when I introduced this new logic into
the game of variance the skilled player
loses their edge and the amateur gains a
enormous edge I kind of believe that and
when you apply that logic to the Bitcoin
protocol and you look at how the
two-week difficulty adjustment is so far
away from the four years having event
and that you try to hold the price at
this intrinsic value that it was done by
design in order to creat volatility so
that you could have unskilled players
compete at the highest level with the
most skilled players in the world I mean
it would make sense right in terms of at
least that's what we're seeing the the
final product kind of you know present
itself as and to me one of the things
that I always go back to is like was it
intentional or not right and some people
would argue oh there's no way that you
could know through game theory the
volatility and
the leveling of the playing field
between skill sets you know yada yada
yada whatever well at the end of the day
you can say whether it was intentional
or not but that's where we are today
because that's what it does do right and
the volatility that is what it does and
so you kind of walk through this stuff
and it's not an argument ever on is this
true is this not true it's always an
argument people will go back specially
to tractors and argue on was this the
intention of the design which i think is
frankly you know not really an argument
worth having because it is what it is
and these are the facts that we have
today and we can see how they're playing
out you know in kind of practicality on
a daily basis you know one of the things
that I read and this is going back to
that book the book of satoshi where it's
all his quotes the kind of you know
encapsulated into a single book early on
there were people that were this is
whenever WikiLeaks was going having
issues with how they were gonna receive
payment and so all these people started
showing up on these Bitcoin forums and
saying hey this is our big opportunity
let's let's have WikiLeaks run Bitcoin
on the website and you know what
satoshis response was he was adamantly
opposed to this adamantly opposed to it
he says no we we are not at the point
where we need attention right now and so
for me that specifically that specific
engagement in that specific quote for in
the book was really powerful because he
knew very well that he needed a lot of
time and he needed a lot of entrenchment
and he needed a lot of refinement to
make this thing become a global currency
and it just further compounded my belief
that the the Trojan horse analogy was a
deep very deep time fuse that I think he
was airing on the side of caution by
pushing the four-year having psycho
aisle to to the date that he ended up
using
because he really knew that this thing
needed time to to churn to get that that
entrenchment into the existing financial
rails do you think Satoshi is somewhere
still watching this and saying wow it's
playing out how I designed hell yeah I
tend to agree with you it's uh it's
pretty crazy to see all this play out
again just so quickly what's your
favorite book that you've ever read
you're a very well-read person so what's
your favorite or most important you've
ever read
dude that's a hard question well the
more you read the harder it is yeah it
really depends on what the topic is that
you're that you're talking about I would
if I had to pick a book I would say it
would really revolve around habits
because you know early on I just had no
idea how profound that is to really kind
of master your habits so the power of
habit is a really really good book by
Charles Duhigg and another one that I
think is also really good is atomic
habits both of those books are going to
give you some insights into basically
how you condition your mind you know
when I when I look at how the brain
works and you look at your neocortex
it's it's they're trying to solve like
the problems at hand in the the the
things that are right there in front of
you right now you can do all that your
heart math problems with that but almost
all your processing is actually in your
sub in your subconscious in the rest of
your brain and and all these things are
happening and they're happening based
off of habit loops that that you have
established so you know you you even
have I mean this is the thing that I
think a lot of people don't even
understand is you have you know on your
spinal cord going down you have you have
gray matter clear down there and you're
in your spinal cord and so like you eat
a strawberry goes down in your stomach
and all those neural Nets are firing as
to exactly how your stomach needs to
secrete certain ass
kids and how all of that's taking place
subconsciously and you don't even
realize it so think about think about
the things you do all day long and you
think about your senses that are
providing this cueing into your
subconscious brain and the
decision-making that is happening that
you are not even aware of and let me
tell you it is way more profound than
people realize
how many decisions you're making on a
daily basis that have nothing to do with
what's happening inside of your
neocortex or your critical thinking
portion of your brain so those books for
me are really powerful because when you
think about what is it that I want to
become where am I going how am I gonna
get there
you then have to break it down into what
are the habits that are gonna be neat
that that I'm gonna need in order to get
there and then you've got to just start
conditioning them like they're it's a
deep neural net machine learning cut
type algorithm in order to achieve that
so like if you're gonna play let's say
you want to become great at chess well
the only way you're gonna get there is
by doing it as often as you can and
probably doing it right before you sleep
because then as you sleep your your
brain is basically re simulating all
that stuff that you learn especially at
the end of the day all of that stuff to
me is fascinating how the brain works
well it's I could give you a million
book recommendations but I tell people
focus on your habits focus on what it is
you're trying to achieve understand what
that is I like to use the analogy that
you're on a boat and a lot of people are
just out in the water and they're
letting that boat blow them all over the
place and in order to achieve what it is
that you want out of life you have to
say first of all what's the destination
define the destination then as you're on
that sailboat
you you can control the sail and you can
control the rudder those are your two
things that you can control you cannot
control the wind it might be blowing
straight into your face and when people
see wind blowing into their face they
might say well that's impossible I can't
sail straight into the wind but guess
what you can you can tack into the wind
so you might not be able to control your
environment which would be the wind but
you can absolutely control some things
in your life and once you master what
those are and you understand what what
those controls are whether it's the sail
or the or the rudder once you control
with this once you understand how to
control what those are you can go
anywhere you want
and I think one of the best ways to be
able to control the rudder on the sail
is to understand how to work your habits
in your life and so I would recommend
those two books I love thoughts on
aliens before I let you go believe it or
not believer oh absolutely
that's that one's easy what is just the
the universe is so massive just it's
unbelievably massive I mean I would get
into here I guess the better way to
answer your question is how do you
define an alien I'm assuming you're
describing it as some type of organism
that assembles you know different
chemicals into a certain order but yeah
this is if you're using that definition
absolutely I think that there's it's
just way too big for there not to be
some type of life even in the most
elementary form whether it's just like
microorganism or something you can ask
you one question to finish up what you
got for me oh I like this all right uh
how you're not gonna like this question
but I'm gonna ask it so you're on you're
on squawk box all the time and I can
honestly say I laugh my tail off when
you're on that show because you are just
this calm consummate professional that
is literally just laying down truth
bombs on that show at all times and
you're doing it and it's such a manner
that it seems like it seems like they're
not truth bombs because you're just
talking about it so casually and just so
nonchalantly but for anybody who
understands what you're saying it is
comical to watch the expression
especially on Sorkin's on Andrew
Sorkin's face right he just he is not
there he is not getting this whole
Bitcoin thing at all and I guess my
question for you is what the hell are
the conversations once they break - a
lot of kamar
I've been on that set before they go to
a lot of commercials and there's a lot
of sidebar chats what are the sidebar
chats with you that we don't hear so
I'll give you three examples the first
is there's a lot of non Bitcoin talk
right so like they'll explain here's the
types of assets that we do own they
actually don't own a lot of assets they
don't want to appear bias etc so it's a
lot of kind of talk about that now it's
just more of my me driving that
conversation of personal curiosity over
time to is one thing I will say so for
those who've never been to the set
basically you walk out there you know a
couple minutes before you're gonna go on
and do your segment and now when I've
walked out there they just light up
right and Joe and they're all smiling
and and it's just like oh it's time to
talk about Bitcoin pumps he here and
it's just kind of like is this real or
is this not in their opinion right
they're still trying to figure it out
like you said and so to them it's more
of like this is gonna be fun which i
think is a good thing frankly for me and
then for for Bitcoin too but but that's
always just kind of the reaction and
then the last couple of times that I've
been on there's been other people with
me and the one example that just cracked
me up was the last the second time I was
on with Kevin O'Leary
as I sat down he just looked at me and
he just had this smirk on his face and
he said you ready to do it again because
the first time we had gotten into a
whole thing and and I said yeah of
course and he goes how much of your uh
your net worths in this nonsense and I
told him and then sure enough as soon as
the camera turns on he was just waiting
it was like a piece of bait and he
immediately asked me the question and
when we got done he cuz I couldn't
resist and so I think that what you end
up finding is they just want to have fun
right and they're they're doing a great
job I think delivering the news and and
trying to educate people and keep people
informed but at the same time they want
to have fun and be entertaining etc and
so that the conversations are quite uh
quite hilarious but the one thing I will
say is Joe went from
complete non-believer - literally asking
you know secretary Munchen what do you
mean there's no money laundering with
the dollar right and so anytime you can
get a host to just serve up his own
truth bombs
I think we've we've kind of accomplished
our mission there I'm I'm kind of
surprised I would have suspected that
Becky or Andrew would have been the
first adopters and so when Joe came off
I mean man Joe is hardcore now it's it's
kind of amazing to see him just be all
in on it
so yeah dude you are doing such a
service I want to personally thank you
on behalf of the people that are in my
community I mean it is such a pleasure
and it is downright hilarious to watch
some of the stuff that you say on that
show because I can just literally see it
flying straight over people's heads and
and you're just saying it in a way that
is exactly how we want the community to
to say it on that show so dude you're
crushing it absolutely love it I
appreciate very much where can uh where
can people find you online where where
should they go learn more stuff so I'm
on Twitter you can just find me at
Preston last name is py Sh Preston pish
I also have a podcast called we study
billionaires we pretty much just try to
read whatever book we can find that a
billionaire investor is recommended or
read whatever articles we can and then
we try to talk about whatever moves
they're making in in the markets to try
to understand what's going on my show is
much more focused on the economy in
general not just specifically Bitcoin
I'm obviously a huge hardcore Bitcoin er
at heart so it's really fun for me to
talk about it but my show is much more
wider in what we cover from us from all
the different types of securities but
yeah I appreciate the opportunity to
provide that handoff it's called we
study billionaires on the Apple Store
absolutely listen I appreciate you
coming on and spending so much time to
do this and you are dropping your own
truth
on Twitter so we'll definite to keep
doing this more often in the future so
thanks so much loved it thanks for the
opportunity pump